[موسيقى]
اخبر العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم بعد انتهاء مهله وقف اطلاق النار
في السودان اشتباكات ضاريه بمختلف انواع
الاسلحه في العاصمه الخرطوم بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع وبحثات افريقيه في
جيبوتي تتصدرها الازمه السودانيه رئيس
جيبوتي يدعو لوقف فوري لاطلاق النار ورئيس
كينيا يطالب قاده الايجاد بوضع حد في
الحرب الجيش الاوكراني يقول انه احرز
تقدما شرقي البلاد ويؤكد استمرار هجماته
جنوب شرقي زفروجيا موسكو تقول انها احبطت
محاوله اوكرانيا لمهاجمه قطعه بحريه روسيه
في البحر الاسود وتؤكد انها لا ترى اي
اساس لبناء حوار مع اوكرانيا المرشد
الايراني يقول ان طهران لا تعارض ابرام
اتفاقيات بشان ملفك النووي شريطه الحفاظ
على البنيه التحتيه لصناعتها النوويه
ولتنيغو يؤكد ان اسرائيل ستفعل كل ما يلزم
لحمايه نفسها بغض النظر عن التوصل الى
اتفاق مع ايران للمره الاولى في تاريخه
مانشستر سيتي الانجليزي وتوجه بلقب دوريه
ابطال اوروبا بفوزه على انتر ميلان
والايطالي بهدف دون مقابل في المباراه
النهائيه التي اقيمت في مدينه اسطنبول هذا
وتتجه الانظار اليوم الاحد الى اياب الدور
النهائي من دوري ابطال افريقيا الذي يجمع
بين الوداد المغربي حامل اللقب وظيفه
الاهلي المصري
الى اللقاء